what's going on bro what's up what's up
with you what's up it's it's kind of
crazy man my my story sounds a lot like
Charlie in terms of just I'm just too I
feel I'm too logical to believe in in
that Jesus is God because
I yeah I have a hard time basically if a
God is all knowing and all powerful how
does he create something like this not
knowing what's going to
happen create something like what
like me so he knows I before he made me
million years ago he knows I'm going to
deny Jesus so why would a just person
create me knowing million years ago
because he's all knowing and he's lived
forever that he's gonna create me walk
the path that I'm gonna walk because he
knows what I'm gonna walk and then still
send me to hell I can't Rectify that in
my mind went to Islam Islam made me go
completely just a I read it I was what
I'm Ethiopian bro it says in there in
Ethiopian is supposed to go and blow up
the kabat after I read that I was like
bro I'm done yeah you done well let's
let's let's talk about this really quick
then let's talk about your your griev so
so so far are you are you an atheist are
you agnostic what are you so far I think
if there's a God out there I don't think
it's an either he's not all powerful or
he's not omnip whatever that word all
knowing
omnip it it might be some guy running an
experiment on this or something no way
you know what I mean and that for me is
not worthy of worship well you okay well
you said you're logical so obvious let's
let's let's do this let's logically
break this stuff down man let's
logically work our way through this okay
so you're saying that it's it's wrong
for God to create you
knowing that you that you will deny
him right but if God created you and he
knows your steps and knows everything
that you're going to
do um why do you deny him if he created
you I don't I don't feel like no I I
deny that he should know better and not
create Us in that manner of where we're
going to sin and be punished he knew
this 10 billion years ago wait wait wait
that that don't answer the question if
if you're saying that he created you
knowing that you will deny him why are
you denying your
creator cuz I don't think he's a just
Creator so I'm not Den like I I need
more evidence for God in other ways but
I'm saying I'm denying that he's worthy
of worship right if you're denying that
he's worthy of worship that means that
okay God being a relational being right
he gives you the free will to love him
back he loves you but real love is dealt
within Free Will choice right you can't
force somebody to love you because
that's not love that's right so God
creates you so why why does God need
that he does that sounds like a vain but
that needs me my love mg that's I didn't
say that he needs your love this is this
is not this is not his need this is not
his necessity this is just you know he
creates it says that in the Testament is
a needs our love it never says a jealous
God why is he jealous that is true is it
but is all is is all jealousy wrong
mg is all jealousy wrong no man not all
it's a just jealousy if yeah exactly so
he's if he's your right if he's your
creator but it goes back to what I said
he needs it
no if he's your creator mg if he's your
creator who molded you who created you
gave you your mind gave you the number
of hairs that you have on your head gave
you the breath that you breathe in your
body every single day even though you
reject
him doesn't he have a right to be
jealous if you give um this adoration or
this credit to something other than
him that's a just jealousy right does he
have a right to do that I he does have a
right to do that if you're thinking it
from a from a a human mindset logical
mindset yeah but as a God I feel like a
god should be above that that's my like
that's how I but but again you're you're
saying you're saying what you you're
saying God should be like but if if God
is showing you what he is God Made You
In His Image meaning he's giving you a
mind and intellect Free Will and
emotions right self-awareness You're
Made In His Image and us being able to
recognize a just jealousy is or anything
just in in any way comes from him the
fact that okay so if that's if that's
thew if that's the angle you're going
we're in them image then I also have
more reasons not to trust that God
because he can also do wrong if I made
his image and I can do wrong he can also
be wrong and incorrect no that's
not mg I need you to pay attention to
what I'm saying and please like deal
with what I'm saying don't don't straw
at me I didn't say that he's flawed like
you I'm saying that there the
characteristics
the and the good characteristics
recognizing Justice and morality having
intellect that's what's being made in
his that's what being made in this image
means not your flawed nature you having
the the ability to do wrong and have
wrong in you that's not in God he's
perfect and holy you're not where did
that come from where where did what come
from the flaw the flaw flawless like
where did that come it's in you it's in
it's in you your your own will to to do
the wrong thing rather than the right
thing that's your free will to do that
but that was created by God he your free
will is created by God not you not the
wrong in you you're when you're to when
you're yourself are doing the wrong deed
doing the sin breaking the crime God
didn't make you do
that he gave you the choice you can
choose him or choose the wrong thing to
do your choice and then when you choose
the wrong thing that's on you that's not
on God no I understand no no it is
eventually cuz he's the one that gave me
Free Will that's not on God that's on
you it's on both of us cuz like how can
you how can you say that this dog is
bugging bro how can you say that God
created Me In His Image but it's only
the good but where did the bad come from
I get it's the free will but God creates
everything so he to also create the evil
where where do you get this idea of bad
from well I mean where do you the same
place you get the like are you are you
trying to tie this back to like morality
being with God and things like that okay
no that's that is a good
argument so where does evil come from So
You logically understand that even the
concepts of morality all originate With
God all this stuff goes back to God so
you acknowledge God exist you're just
saying I don't I just don't think he's
just I don't think he's Incorruptible I
think he has mistakes I think he makes
mistakes he's better than us but he's
also just another being seems to me
based on all these texts from all
religions and all even the Bible you can
see it you can see the jealousy in him
you can see but again but again you
acknowledge that there is a jealousy
that is just so with him being
jealous worshiping UGA you know it's not
wrong to be jealous it's still an ugly
trait even if it's in the just cause
how is it is it is it an ugly trait are
you married by the way no not yet okay
but let's say let's say you were married
isn't an ugly trait if your wife slept
with another man and you felt way about
that is that an ugly trait in you uh so
the feeling no but condemn like you know
doing something about it to that person
because of that like yeah so so let's
let's say that you let's say that you go
off on your wife and you reprimand her
for sleeping with another man you're you
you're wrong for reprimanding her for
doing that
no I see your point I see your point so
it's the same I feel like God should be
above all that man no but see there's
the thing there there when you're when
you recognize a just there's there's a
just jealousy a righteous jealousy is
what we call the Bible calls it a
righteous jealousy there's not a flaw in
this jealousy he's perfectly within his
right to be jealous right and it's a
righteous jealousy you have no business
giving any type of
adoration uh or attention to anything
other than the one who created you the
one who made you which is God himself
he's he's the best thing for you why
would you go to something else lesser
that's him wanting the be he he's the
perfect being he's the perfect being no
flaw in him I disagree that's where the
my that's I guess where but but if it's
the I got you but if it's the case that
he is if it's if it's case you said he's
better than us he's better say he's
better than anything in in the known
universe that we know of right he's the
best thing that we know of is it
wouldn't it be loving that he offers
himself to us if he loves us and he's
the best thing wouldn't he want the best
thing for us which would be
himself yeah but he could
also made life better for us you know
what I mean he also had that option and
the and and this and here's the option
the he should he he would want life to
be better for us and so the option in
wanting life better for us is to be in
him to be one in him to follow him to
obey him we do
that life is better for
us period we don't then we suffer the
consequence God wants us to be in
monogamous relationships one man one
woman if I don't that if I don't and I
want to go sleep with many women what
are the what are the options that are
out there
STDs right sexual transed diseases yeah
deadly diseases um hurt feeling hurt and
and emotional turmoil all of these
things I understand so so to me the way
I look at religion religion is like a
technology I think religion is good like
I don't like talking to people about
religion because I think people need
structure I think we're all most people
are just insane and they need structure
that's why I don't talk to Muslims about
what I don't what what I dislike about
the Quran say thing about the Bible I
think people need religion okay to guide
them right okay because they don't I
feel like they lack something inside of
them especially 200 years ago you know
what I mean that was a way to organize a
society and structure it it's a lot
easier because if you don't fear the man
you got to fear the guy upstairs that's
a lot easier to say that's that's a good
way to that's the same way Muhammad
ended up leading and and uniting the
Arab tribes to take over the world
that's
like okay religion the
most so so far what we got is that one
religion is a it's a good thing and I
would agree depending on if it's the
right one but it's a good thing right
believing in God believing some higher
power brings stability in some sense two
we've we've surmised that there is a
righteous jealousy and and even so that
God offering us himself would be the
most loving thing to do that he can do
because he is the best I think he can do
more okay but that is lovely as well but
I think he could do more but that is
okay so he's loving he's loving us by
offering us himself which would which is
the best thing for us and so if we
reject him and deny him and we don't
want to be with him isn't it loving of
him to say okay fine you can be I'll
give you what you want you can be
without me and what comes with that
comes with that but isn't it loving if
someone if you really love a person
okay go yeah right so if God creates you
God creates you and he gives you the
free will to choose him or to not choose
him and he he's the best choice for you
but you choose
otherwise and the otherwise Choice
that's not God is a Eternal separation
for him no life right Darkness outer
darkness nashing of teeth anguish and
despair that's life without him you
choose that
instead of life with him and abundance
and Grace
how is he wrong for giving you what you
want because I feel like he's playing
games simple as
that the one playing games is you B it
feels like what he's doing is he's
running an experiment on us hey where
you love me because I love you I created
you he's playing games and I to me
personally as a logical person you know
like I don't mind when people give you
know shout out to God I'm like yeah
maybe God did do that for you but he's
playing games with us bro here on Earth
he he's playing games with us that's how
I look at it the other way around I have
that disdain but I don't say this to
people and I was I really didn't want to
come up bro because I don't want to put
doubt on other people because I I
honestly think Society needs religion
bro like they're they're you're fine
you're fine here man you can see I don't
want to put doubt like the last guy
Charlie
like talking like the Giants and stuff I
say the same thing man like for me Jesus
is like if ml if Martin Luther lived
2,000 years ago there have been a
religion about him bro turn the other
cheek that that's just another Rome was
basically United States it's it's just
all but this this but this is where
we're at I think that you're projecting
the game playing unto God which is
really you're the one doing it dude it's
not God playing games you're playing
games with him man you see his commands
you acknowledge that he makes sense you
acknowledge that he exists you
acknowledge that his commands are what's
good for for us even if you think that
there can be better but you acknowledge
that these are good for us yeah um so
why not follow him and submit to him
rather than the alternative that's you
playing games not him he's very
straightforward it's this or that black
or white this is the best for you this
is the worst for you you have the option
he's not playing games he gives you the
option to
choose that's that's literally a game
he's sitting there
pick a pride that's not a game that's
literally a game that's a game show what
what's behind this
suitcase it's a proposal man prop you
propos to when you propose to your wife
is that is that a game you playing games
no no no no I'm not no I won't you're
not playing games man will you choose me
that's not a game being played but this
is what it is God is proposing to you
you can reject his proposal or accept
his proposal
yeah I I want to leave you with that um
what brother I appreciate you man um
yeah B hey I like the work you do
honestly I like the logic aspect you
apply I you still haven't sold me on it
but maybe we'll have another maybe next
time come back again come back again I
like to talk to you again I like this
it's cool for sure brother I appreciate
you man you too man take care mg